what's the most difficult sign in las
vegas to maintain can you tell me about
that a little
yeah the harvard wall is unique because
a lot of our signs in las vegas we can
access them from a lift or from behind
like the aria we climb up inside that
sign we can service it from inside
harmony is unique that it's right up
against a wall so the only way to get to
that
entire giant screen is to rappel off the
edge which even to get up the edge it's
an elevator
a roof a ladder a roof and another
ladder cage ladder all the way to the
parapet and then we have uh certified
propellers that that go off the edge to
take care of that thing so that that
part is right it's not the only place we
repel
but it's one of the largest screens
we've done in town
and so just in terms of scale
it has its complexities
on that corner of harmon
there are more leds on that corner than
we can think of anywhere that we know of
if you consider cosmopolitan
and
the harman sign across the street and
planet hollywood
there's a lot of leds
burning there and you know we're taking
care of all those